How's it going everyone and welcome back
to another video. In this video we are
going to be talking about classic
expansion or the first video in my
weekly profile series. So let's get into
the PDF. So what does a classic
expansion week look like? A classic
expansion week is exactly how it sounds,
a classic expansion. It is a directional
candle or an expansion candle. And so
what do we want to look for that is we
first want to determine a bias. This is
generally going to occur after we have a
reversal candle on the weekly time frame
or we're looking for price to expand in
one direction.
So once we have that bias, then we can
anticipate the lower time frame or the
daily time frame in this case. And what
does that have? We have Monday or
Tuesday forming the high of the week in
a bearish scenario or Monday or Tuesday
forming the low of the week in a bullish
scenario. Then we get multiple days of
expansion into a key level or once we
hit our average range and then we have
Friday capping off the weekly range. So
let's take a look at what this actually
looks like. So combining it with my
fractal model, we'll have the high or
low formed on Tuesday. And so what will
that look like? We'll have a candle two
closure on Monday or Tuesday. And then
what do we want to check with a candle
two closure? We want to see at that high
or the low of the week if that is paired
with an hourly change in the state of
delivery. So here you can see we have a
bearish candle two closure. We want to
check inside this wick to make sure we
have a change in the state of delivery.
That confirms that this wick has formed
and we can look to trade away from it
for the rest of the week. And here in
the bullish scenario, the same thing. I
want to make sure that I have a bullish
change in the state of delivery
confirming this wick low and I can look
to trade higher. Now with that candle
two closure confirmed, I can look to
trade Wednesday or candle three. And if
candle three closes well, then I can
also look to trade candle four. and I'll
give me my two to three days of
expansion, and then I want to see if we
hit that higher time frame key level.
Once we have expanded or hit a key
level, that is when Friday can cap the
weekly range. So, just review, what is a
classic expansion week? It is when we
have the higher low formed on a Monday
or Tuesday. So, in a bullish scenario,
the low is formed on Monday or Tuesday.
In a bearish scenario, the high is
formed on Monday or Tuesday. From there,
we have multiple days of expansion, and
that is generally Tuesday, Wednesday,
Thursday, or Wednesday, Thursday,
Friday.
From that, if we hit our higher time
frame key level, or we've already
expanded, we can see a little
retracement towards the end of the week
that caps out our weekly candle. And
that is what we also call TGIF, which
I'll also put out a video on. Now that
you understand what this actually looks
like, let's get into TradingView and go
over a few examples. So, here we are
with our first example, and let's take a
look at the higher time frames to get
some context. So, here we are on the
daily chart. What do we notice? You can
see we have swept out these previous
highs right there, and then we have
retraced, right? And why do I say this
is a retracement not a reversal on the
higher time frames? Well, we have taken
out these swing lows here into this gap,
and then we have formed a V-shape
reversal. So, you can see that V-shape
reversal is paired with an order block,
and this is going back with the trend
higher. So, what can be our targets for
this move higher? We have these swing
highs above. Now, due to the fact that
they have some decent separation between
the two, I will mark them both out. So,
the goal with weekly profile is not to
predict is this going to be a Monday low
of the week, a Tuesday low of the week,
Wednesday low of the week? The whole
goal is to let the low of the week form,
and then look to trade. So, I'm going to
let Monday play out. With this candle
closure here, can I anticipate that the
low of the week has formed? If the
answer is no, then I let another day
form. If the answer is yes, then I can
look to trade the next day. But looking
at this day, this is a nice bearish
expansion candle. So I'll let another
day print. And here you can see we have
a nice aggressive move with a candle to
closure. So taking a look at that, I can
anticipate that the low of the week has
formed because one, we have a candle to
closure, but we've also formed a
continuation or a close through the
series of down close candles here.
Now what is the next step that I have to
follow when looking for this to confirm
the low of the week? I go down to the
hourly time frame. Down here on the
hourly time frame, I want to see do we
have a change in the state of delivery?
Well, taking a look, here is our sweep
and our candle to closure. We have a
change in the state of delivery there as
marked out by my indicator. So with
that, I can look for continuations when
the following days. So if Tuesday's
forming the low, I can look for
Wednesday's continuation higher.
So letting Wednesday play out, what do
we get?
We get a nice continuation higher. Now
since Wednesday closed higher and had a
continuation, didn't form a reversal
candle, I can also look for the
following day or Thursday to form a
continuation.
And here you can see we get that
continuation higher on Thursday.
Now why would I not want to look for
another continuation here? Well, we've
already had three days of expansion.
Tuesday's expanded, Wednesday and
Thursday has expanded. And if we go back
out to the daily time frame, we've hit
those higher time frame objectives. So
we've had a Tuesday low a week,
Wednesday continuation,
Thursday continuation. Why would I want
to look for a continuation on Friday
when we already over our targets? I
wouldn't. So letting that next day play
out, this is something that I would
avoid trading. But this is an example of
a classic expansion. Now let me Now let
me review one more time. We retrace on
Monday or Monday opposes the range.
Tuesday forms a low with a candle two
closure. We confirm that with an hourly
change in the state of delivery inside
of that. And then Wednesday we get a
continuation and Thursday we get a
continuation. So if you understand my
fractal model, I'm trying to pair candle
two closures with the weekly profile to
trade candle three and candle four or in
this case Wednesday and Thursday. Let's
get into another example. So here we are
in another example and let's take a look
at this structure here. We have yet to
take out this previous high here. So we
have equal highs setting up. So that
leaves a nice target for this next week.
So let's see what happens. We have a
protected swing right here.
And then we have a new protected swing
right here as this reaches into a fair
value gap, retests this level, and
closes through.
So let's see what happens on Monday
here. Monday you can see we oppose our
anticipated bias, which is what we want
to see. We want to see the weekly candle
open low then reach for its high and
close. Now is this a candle two closure?
No, we can't anticipate the low of week
to have formed yet. So we need to let
another candle close. Here you can see
we now have a candle two closure in a
point of interest, right?
In this fair value gap and this opposing
candle here. So we have a candle two
closure and we can look for this to
trade higher. Now what do we go to next?
The hourly time frame. Down here on the
hourly time frame, do we have an
opposing candle or a change in the state
of delivery? We do. As this low, we find
a series of candles that made it. Have
we closed through it? We have, which
confirms this low. So now we can look
for a continuation higher in this next
candle or on Wednesday.
You can see we have a little
consolidation. We sweep it out and then
go higher. Now with this strong close
through, we can also seek another
continuation as it's clearly not
manipulating off of this high.
So, let's see what happens.
There you can see, we expand higher as
well. Now, once we have two really big
days of expansion, this is harder to
anticipate a third day of expansion
here. And so, then that's when I want to
avoid it, right? As we can consolidate
or get in new phase of price.
So, just review, go back to the daily
chart here. What do we have? We have a
Tuesday low of the week or a classic
expansion that's paired with an hourly
change in the state of delivery, which
allows us to anticipate Wednesday to
expand. And since we closed strong on
Wednesday, Thursday to expand. Now, this
weekly candle has already made a lot of
range, so it's harder to anticipate a
further expansion on Friday as we have
already expanded and we didn't close
well on Thursday.
So, let's get into another example. Now,
a classic expansion does not have to
form a low on Tuesday. It can also form
a low on Monday. So, what are we
noticing here? You can see, we have
Friday expanding into an objective,
right? So, we have taken out on this
move down this swing low here that made
that high.
So, we can anticipate a new phase of
price here, but do we have a candle
closure? No. So, we let another candle
print. And what do we have? Open low and
now we are moving higher. So, we have
formed a wick on the weekly time frame
and we have that candle to closure. Now,
I want to see on the hourly time frame,
do I have a change in the state of
delivery?
And you can see, we do have that change
in the state of delivery.
As you can see, we have made a low.
The series of candles that made that low
have been closed through. So, with
Monday forming the low, we can
anticipate Tuesday to continue higher
and we have some nice targets above
here. Let's see what happens on Tuesday.
You can see, we don't have the best
structure, but we do have a nice move
higher and we do close over Monday's
high. So, now we can also anticipate
Wednesday it continue higher.
And here you can see, we get an
expansion on Wednesday and we have taken
out all these highs over here. Now with
Monday, Tuesday, and Wednesday
expanding, this is generally when I want
to avoid price as we can get a new phase
of price even if we do expand higher.
You can see that is a great time to
avoid price. So going back to the daily
time frame, let's review. Monday forms a
low, we can get a Tuesday continuation,
and a Wednesday continuation. And so
this would also be an example of a
classic expansion weekly profile. So
here we have another example and what do
we notice about this low right here?
What is it missing? It is missing an
important level.
It made equal lows right here and what
do we have is a fair value gap above. So
although it is ideal for Monday to have
a shallow opposing run of the weekly
range, sometimes it doesn't always occur
that way.
What do we notice on Tuesday here? We
have a candle two closure. Going ahead
and marking that out. What do we want to
check for next? An hourly change in the
state of delivery.
Now what do we notice about this?
We do not have that hourly change in the
state of delivery yet. So it's not
confirmed until we get the closure
through.
You can see on this day, we have open
high
and then there we get the change in the
state of delivery. So now we can
anticipate if we have a protected swing
here and then we retrace back into the
range and form a protected swing here as
well. We can expect this to continue
lower throughout the day if it's going
to expand.
And there we go. With Wednesday closing
below Tuesday's low, we can expect
further continuation on Thursday.
And you can see do we get an expansion?
Yes, we do.
And then now
although we have had two days of
expansion, we haven't yet hit an
objective. This is where I either want
to avoid price or seek a further
continuation lower on Friday.
And you can see it is quite choppy.
But that is just another example. If we
go back to the daily chart here, we have
Monday which actually forms the low of
the week, but we also do have a Tuesday
reversal. So, although this isn't a
classic expansion, it is still Tuesday
forming the high of the week and seeking
a continuation in Wednesday and Thursday
and even Friday if you want. So, this
goes to show that not every weekly
profile is perfect. That's not the point
of this. It's to focus on finding the
reversal or the high or the low of the
week forming and then seeking a
continuation in the days following. That
is how weekly profile works. It's not
trying to match templates together, but
instead finding the high or the low of
the week and then trading continuations.
With that, I hope you enjoyed this
video. If you did, please consider
liking and subscribing. I'll see you
guys next time. Have a good one.